at any moment the house will vote on
president trump's stimulus demand
to increase direct payments to americans
from 600
to 2000. president trump signing a
massive covid relief and government
spending package into law last night
after
railing against its price tag and pork
barrel spending with complaints like
this
i am asking congress to amend this bill
and increase the ridiculously low
six hundred dollars to two thousand
dollars or
four thousand dollars for a couple i'm
also asking congress to immediately get
rid of the wasteful and unnecessary
items
from this legislation trump taking
issue with spending like 40 million
dollars for the kennedy center in
washington
one billion dollars for the smithsonian
institution
seven million for reef fish management
and 25 million to combat
invasive asian carp but tonight's vote
won't address the pork trump wants to
cut and faces a tough road ahead in the
senate
republicans oppose adding more to the
debt and say the spending should be
targeted
to people who actually need it it's
terribly untargeted right
why would we be sending two thousand
dollars to people with
a six-figure income who've had no
suspension no reduction of their income
at all
this money isn't sitting on a shelf
we're going to print it or we're going
to borrow it
and i think that the age should be much
much more targeted it should be targeted
to people who've actually lost their job
we're in this situation of crisis
because of nancy pelosi politicizing
this
her refusal to deliver covert relief
because most of the provisions were very
bipartisan
whether it was the paycheck protection
program whether it was support for
hospitals or vaccination distribution
those were bipartisan agreements that we
could have gotten done earlier this year
had it not been for speaker pelosi
sean duffy i want to start with you as a
former congressman
part of the issue here is that in an
unprecedented year
with an unprecedented pandemic congress
seems to be operating
as usual and every congressman that we
talk to on this network says oh
here's the problem and here's the issues
but can you break down for viewers right
now
what is the problem and what is the
issue from your insider
perspective yeah absolutely it's great
to be with you so the problem is that
we're
doing a coveted spending bill right at
christmas time when this congress is
about to end in less than a week
the new congress has signed into office
this should have been done in september
or october
where there was plenty of time to get a
bill done and republicans rightfully are
angry that there's so much pork in this
bill you just
talked about some of it and toomey was
spot on he says this money isn't
targeted we don't want to
help retirees who are out on the golf
course we don't want to help you know
folks who
who who haven't lost any income because
they're government employees
you have some people who haven't worked
for the last five years all of them are
going to get a 2
000 check that doesn't make sense and so
i think you see this divide
in the republican party especially
tonight when this photo is going to come
on board
and i think the backdrop of this emily
is very simple
republicans want the government to open
we don't want to give checks or they
don't want to give checks to the
american people
so new some and and other governors can
keep their economies closed
we want to get people back to work and
making their own income and more money
in handouts lets more state state close
down for longer periods of time
murray to sean's point so if the issue
here in part is not just spending but
it's also saving it's also cutting taxes
and the like
what are your counter arguments to that
and also how
is speaker pelosi's overt politicization
of this spending bill how is that
defensible
well donald trump's the one who refused
to sign the spending bill and by
delaying he actually meant that
millions of americans will lose at least
a week of their unemployment benefits in
the bill
but trump has put republicans in a
really tough position here
tonight the democratic-led house will
pass a bill
that gives americans more relief the
republican senate led by mitch mcconnell
now has a choice
to make do you say no to the american
people we think you can survive on six
hundred dollars especially when there
are two senate seats up
for re-election two republicans running
in these georgia
uh runoff elections in just a few days
so donald trump has put mitch mcconnell
in a really tough position here
and the administration isn't helping
mike pence is skiing in vail
donald trump's at mar-a-lago and steve
mnuchin the key negotiator for the
administration
is on vacation in mexico the democrats
in the house are back at work today
they are tonight voting as you mentioned
they're going to give the american
people more relief
we don't want to give handouts forever
and ever certainly
but this is a pandemic that we have
never seen the likes of in this country
and right now the american people need
that money
not just for themselves emily but to
help the economy the economy
will do better if the american people
have a little bit of relief
as we see this vaccine you know the end
on the horizon
so soon this is a tough place for
republicans in the senate to be in to
say sorry
american people we don't think you
deserve more money during this crisis
lisa to marie's point she's right that
it could have been a lot more a long
time ago
but for according to speaker pelosi
quote republican
obstructionism even though we know there
was a lot of politicization
and complete stalemate on her part
throughout what is your response to that
characterization
well emily we we had this bill months
ago we had this bill back in july if you
look at the heels act
which was in mitch mcconnell in a
republican bill it mirrors the bill that
was just signed in
to law so we could have had this deal
months ago but nancy pelosi
held out for maximum payment paying on
the american people
and to deny president trump a victory
and to marie's criticism
of president trump he has run two of the
most successful government programs we
have ever seen in american history
both with ppp it has saved something
close to 50 million
jobs and as well as operation worm speed
which has now brought two
vaccines to the american people which is
actually a way
to solve the crisis that we're facing so
that we can go back to our lives that we
can live
as normal uh just like we did before and
what have democrats done you look at
liberal leaders whether it's governor
cuomo
whether it's gavin newsom shut down the
economy lock down the economy
kill the middle class kill small
businesses and over what
indoor spread in new york is 1.5 percent
yet they're crushing small businesses
crushing
restaurants when the data the science
doesn't even back that up
so those have been the solutions and the
responses from democrats
lockdowns shutdowns take away your
freedom or
deny the american people the aid that
they need for political purposes
to try to stick it to president trump
and as we're having this conversation
the house has actually begun voting on
this bill so we'll keep you posted on
that
tyrus my question to you is about the
future
and if in this really insane year
if everything proceeded as normal and
we're still having the same argument
back and forth
will it ever change you know what that
that's an amazing question i mean i
guess the good news is is that
when we specifically need something we
can keep it to
two or three pages like when they try to
bring this up to two thousand dollar
stimulus check opposed to
the actual bill which was just a just a
scotch under six thousand pages that
needed to be read in two hours
this is classic holding it to the wire
pelosi did a really good
job waiting to the last minute to where
if anybody opposes it now
they look like the bad guy so you know
this is again we're just gonna steal
with obstruction
and not focusing on the importance of of
the american people that's why it's so
important
that we need term limits so we can stop
this madness they weren't thinking about
the american people when they were
stalling
the the bill is blowing up the president
took one look at it and was like this is
ridiculous
give people more money let's get rid of
the pork bellies but now
if we stretch it out and actually take a
look at it and be physically responsible
we're hurting the american people why
because they they
basically it's a whole football term
where they ran the ball and ate up the
clock
and then gave us this here here you go
and if you don't sign it if you don't
like it
you're hurting the american people and i
think we all see exactly what this is
you don't need glasses to see what's
going on here
amen our